[Music]
look who I found
I have nowhere to go what you mean you
miss me but I thought you didn't want me
no more now do you have simply safe and
I'm a guard dog you mean we can work
together separate safe can help make me
a better guard dog of course it can't
replace me I don't know what I was
thinking
super SEP can help monitor and one but
it can't scare and bite it bad guys like
bag hopper can Oh No buggers quick right
everybody
[Music]
last week for the promo we do one live
read per week usually it's from ugh
levelness we have an awesome sponsor
this last week simply safecom slash
creditor simply safe is the home
security system I think I told you I've
had home security systems before mostly
because I moved into a house and they
were already in there
they were wired and they sucked and so I
relied on hopper I put too much stress
on his shoulders so simple steve has an
entirely wireless system you can hook it
up it's awesome I think of one CNET and
TechRadar won all kinds of awards it's
$15 a month no contract and if you order
right now at simply safecom slash
Crowder you still get 10% off this is
the last week of the promo I believe
going into Christmas so if you don't
need a home security system then okay
you don't need home don't don't buy one
if you live in a place that I say if you
if you live next to the Hope Diamond
you're probably fine but if you do or
you've ever thought about getting a home
security system I will tell you about
for this and I'm not just doing the
radio thing will vouch for products that
they never use that's what we have so
few sponsors I use it I like it
I have family and friends who use it and
like it is the easiest home security
system to install and the most reliable
but don't take my word for it said levar
burton but you don't need to take the
word of a six year old kid reading a pop
out book either but simply safecom slash
crowd or 10% off this is the last week
fifteen dollars a month no contract no
course just do it or just you know take
your chances who knows who can get in
[Music]
[Music]
right now how much do you really love
your children how much do you really
love you join my club don't kill your
kids join my club will kill your kids
join them don't kids join our club will
kill your
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
how about this watching the old watch
the old movies like an old wait I got
Fred Astaire what's that story like it
was so innocent back in Sligo look how
innocent movies were yeah I see a Puerto
Rican shaking her tits right as she goes
up and the guys it's just we just veiled
knew a move you can make today musicals
seven boxes and brothers yeah you can't
that's basically just kidnap and sexual
misconduct all right
producing with me we have Clint Howard
today Williams Larry white a survey quiz
with Blaire white from everyday feminism
calm and intersectional feminist quiz
stick around for that
when Howard will talk about his dad who
recently passed which his dad was an
unbelievable I had an unbelievable
career in the energy ministry and I'm
sure we'll also hear some some other
crazy things it'll talk about producing
opinion video studio as always is Jared
who is now a fellow on Twitter at not
caged air and me that's crowded with
your comments you thought your
photoshop's
I fulfill my legal obligations mostly
Troy your conclusions are we good we're
good and sommelier simplified wine
comment means there's more taste buds in
the rest of us at G Morgan Jr how are
you sir
I'm doing well you know what's the wine
of the day no the wine of the day is
Krupp brothers damsel by the way next
week there are no shows from uh club
members Monday Tuesday Wednesday because
Thursday is the sixteen hour CNN live
stream that's sixteen hours not because
it's worse than waterboarding and we're
going to have guests we're gonna have
the world premiere of the mini series of
YouTube Carol with some unbelievable
cameos in there from 7 a.m. to 11 p.m.
but yes we want to earn your Jimmy drink
well you don't have to be here for the
whole day
actually no yes you do and no you can't
so there you go but Jets bring the wine
huh you know Charlie over there what's
your name no it's the damsel damsel yeah
there you go it's like your girlfriend
in Canada so
the missus will talk about the only
thing in the news Roy Moore how do you
see this I'd like to hear your comments
because I've heard a lot of different
opinions do you see it as a short-term
loss Roy Moore losing for a long term
victories it's a loss as a loss of the
loss do you see do you see it as an
individual screw-up or do you see it
kind of you were saying this before the
break is some people see it as a
referendum on the Republican Party right
yeah so a year what do you think about
that a lot of different opinions and
we'll get to that but before we do we
have to get to other news of the day
[Laughter]
there's a phrase you find herself saying
always a legend warren sapp defending
himself he was proving that he was not a
creep by publicly posting pictures of
the vibrators they bought for female
staff so first let me say why does that
sit why would he okay Daily Mail the
article sap considered by many to be one
of the all-time great defenders in the
league gave the retirement of plaintiff
gave the plaintiff sex toys as a
Christmas gift three years in a row Wow
which would seem bad at first but salve
defended himself pretty valiantly saying
this was taken out of context what they
don't tell you is it on the twelfth day
of Christmas I your true love gave to
the a dildo in a pear tree its context
is keep myself out that Sam in a pear
tree or a partridge in a dildo tree why
three years in a row what kind of usage
with these suits and you're going you
got a dildo three years in a row what
created an environment where this man
was comfortable sending a colleague a
dildo my mom's it's at the snow you snow
like you wanna get our gifts get our
snowman at some point someone should buy
me rolled out books yeah no I don't I
don't I'm not like I just I like Gene
Wilder and now it might have a stack and
I don't need them grandma don't you just
pigeonhole you okay Connecticut man was
sentenced to a year in prison for
necrophilia as well after having sex
with a dead girlfriends corpse
I think he did it in an attempt to
revive her and this is an actual quote
[ __ ] what Aaron gangster said he thought
that sleeping with her body might revive
her because his girlfriend hated
sleeping with them according the arrest
warrant so we can add rape to the
charges this guy was serious and his
answer it would seem absurd except the
rights have already been purchased to
this story by AMC for their tentatively
titled
the [ __ ] debt and they're already
taking auditions we hear how about
instead of bashing zombies we start
loving zombie because it seems like a
waste and Lucille needs a place to hide
that really seems it doesn't have the
same mass appeal no you might find that
in one of the smaller channels might be
premium package robots are now being
used to deter homeless people from
setting up camp in San Francisco scum
social visits inside of the San
Francisco Business Times reported last
week that the San Francisco SPCA an
animal advocacy and pet adoption group
put a security robot to work outside its
facilities the gentrifying mission
neighborhood I understand where you're
coming from and then they're obviously
all kinds of protesters they don't think
that you should be getting rid of
homeless people at all it's a problem
San Francisco though in the I will give
in their defense some of the robots in
question are overkill seems like they're
going a little bit too much that's a
robot on a powered yeah that is exactly
who think if they were trying they were
at least made the Blitz not not white
yeah $7 an hour two is all they pay for
that yes I'm not kidding that's in the
story seven bucks an hour below minimum
wage they do have the black robots that
just put them in Oakland
and they hold the torch sideways a
suburb find itself gonna heat it there's
no good way to get out it's fine stuff
and heated standoff over what the locals
are now claiming is he's a hyper
sexualized logo for an ice cream shop
you see that bear that booty booty I I
get it this is where I thought oh no
that's that's a human ass on a cow yeah
it really seems as though they're
pushing it and of course this is a
growing trend we all know and the food
mascot marketing as seen recently what's
a makeover the Land O'Lakes butter
Indian which you know just hey and then
there was of course the redo of the
sun-maid raisins and yeah a little bit
and then of course it culminated in Tony
the cyber sexting Tiger and it was
unrelated obviously to the hyper
sexualization but there are racial
tensions in the country and people were
obviously upset about and just be
talking about pancake mix and
ill-received
next week is a big big week 16 our lives
yeah save it has been charged with
assault for burning his initials into
his patients livers that's that's
gangstas comes from The Guardian a
renowned liver spleen and pancreas
surgeon used an argon beam I'm reading
that creppy used to stop livers bleeding
during operations and to highlight but
he would sign his initials into the
patient's organ it's hilarious would you
find it so funny for what if it were
your liver as long as it worked I'm fine
[Laughter]
when you get put out all kinds of stuff
can happen buddy I'm just saying that's
true I was always paranoid yeah I'd go
under I've been out for some weird
surgeries yeah I just assume you don't
know what you're signing with that way
that he's going you cry in the shower
and you're good now that's you need you
need to seek counsel this is not a
normal person more film yes crying in
the shadow part of the Rico now does he
always send me the pictures when you do
it's gerald please find somebody to hold
of course the surgeon by the way is no
stranger to controversy given that four
livers just came forward last year
letting me force them to watch and
masturbate in the surgery prep room
seems as though he presses yeah well
they go back to the question today we'll
talk about next Blair White will take
the quiz yes I can only get better
the joke is Roy Moore Roy Moore one
thing is correctly he lost yes and I
mentioned in people's opinions on it but
there been a lot of before we get to the
opinions there were a lot of memes going
around not gay J was wondering she
showed this to me out
it's funny the memes we couldn't find
the source and we find out I think it
was CNN but memes declare that black
women made more lose this is something
you see everywhere right now okay
and I immediately when I watch I get
well of course that's untrue and it's
one of those things we weren't going to
talk about until we realize that most
people if you're not paying attention
they don't know that of course that's
untrue black turnout was up about ten
percent
okay five percent less voted for more
than for Trump so that just it wouldn't
have even been close to change the
election by the way black black voter
turnout is not very good no it really is
no but let's pick up on this fall
because we don't want them there right
yes well I was surprised I think was it
was like 96 what was it he got six
percent of black men which surprised me
that's it hi that's actually already
high for Republicans I think like Donald
Trump was really high with something
like 9 percent of black men I don't I
don't have the numbers in front but the
voters who turn the election just just
to correct the misinformation they were
Trump supporters who didn't vote for
more whether you like Trump or not it's
people who voted for Donald Trump and
didn't vote for more almost half of the
people who voted for President Trump
stayed home Wow
turnout was down 45% 45% in the
presidential election there's a nine
percent drop in support from Trump
tomorrow okay know something tell you
there's a limit to the tribalism yeah it
tells you that Republicans don't just
vote for whoever has an R next to their
name in people say people say that both
sides do it I think both sides have done
I think before President Donald Trump
you know there's a much this goes to
kind of would have talked about it's a
much wider tent with Republicans you
have limit Ariens you have conservatives
you kind of have now the Trump populist
there okay disagreeing with Democrats
there's a Dean exit name they're gonna
vote for yeah I think is age thing too I
think it's an age thing for Republicans
typically the ones that we like are down
ticket no matter what always ever yeah
typically older people
for Republicans I think it's typically
younger people you find more and more
for Democrats seen as all people that
who were you know Bernie Bernie Bernie
only write hate Hillary but still pull
the lever for yeah well one you and I
had this conversation in the 2016
election like oh man we're in a really
tough spot the guy with an R next to his
name isn't exactly the best person for
the job don't think more thoroughly yeah
first off right so we had that I don't
think the Dems have those conversations
nearly as often like oh no they're not
really a good Democrat no they really
just gonna vote D and go it really is
that is one thing they get behind their
candidate and people would try and say
well you have to do that for whether it
was Trump whoever it was you have to get
behind the candidate no matter what
well it's mental gymnastics after that
just to try to say oh I'm still with
this person because they don't even
believe what they say they please well
that's because one is one people say
well why are you want everything you're
a political ideologue people always say
that this means like really this kind of
shows that conservatives are are they're
more principled for sure they're they're
prism their worldview it determines
their values now but it's not based on
an R and ironically people label
themselves Republicans are more likely
to proudly say I'm a conservative
Republican to see guys gonna believe in
labels she killed the guy right yeah
that's okay the head idea was he was
duping kids in the basement well it's
okay what do you think do these a
referendum in the Republican or anything
just write more no I honestly I think I
think it's the the sexual-assault stuff
that's coming out right now we talked
about this a little bit I think right
now you can in you and I probably
disagree a little but you can throw that
out and it's going to sabotage anybody
right now anybody is willing to believe
me because so many examples have come
out we're like oh yeah now this really
is going on so even if there's no
evidence in his case I think there was a
lot of evidence but I think any other
year would have been a little different
story I don't think that's right but I
think it would have been so I don't
think it's a public I think you're kind
of right maybe in in terms of a
temporary bubble but I think temporary a
long term right now people are going
right sexual assault because everything
is sexual is the optics war so everyone
is trying to avoid the optics that's why
that's why I'll Frank it's up down
that's why what with the other guys that
just stepped down from from Ayers
Cornie yeah it's all it's an optics war
it was according someone but that's the
problem like there's legitimate stuff
that we have to fight against in sexual
assault but right now my fear is that
there's no due process for anybody you
throw it out there right now and people
are willing to believe it you and I are
like getting to the point where like
right proof show me proof and I'll
believe it that's why it's a funny me
that they're like what clearly VP Mike
pinch must be a creep yeah what do you
think you think this is do you see this
as a short-term loss that was necessary
do you think that if Roy Moore won it
would have been you talk about the OP
yeah it would've been worse for the
Republican Party long-term long-term
absolutely you do yeah cuz you like I
think we still want him to win I do I I
find myself going back and forth but I
do think long-term you gotta fight the
long term more good things and I think
with Trump if it weren't for the Supreme
Court I think it I think mostly would
have been worth yeah the long term war
to let someone else take it for a little
bit looking back I think Trump is
definitely cause irreparable damage to
the Republican Party of course and the
Supreme Court was really really
important and most most optics it's most
of it is its branding he's rebrand in a
way that it should never been really
represent the people who he's branding
right I think it definitely is better
because Democrats don't really have a
leg to stand on right now politically
there's nothing that they're coming out
with it's really motivating anybody and
so if they could have attacked Roy Moore
with the sexual assault stuff and really
painted him with that yeah they would
have used it Hollywood tape yeah right
with Roy Moore yeah that was really
legitimate and then they'd be like see
that's the kind of guy they want an
office already doing it with Trump so if
they had another person to point to it
just makes it well al franken did it
with his resignation but I do you think
listen this is intriguing to me there is
a silver lining here I'm going hey you
know what regardless of and I do think
listen the media is going it's going to
be hatchet job and Roy more far more
than Al Franken right it's gonna be a
hatchet job on drug war far more than
the Clintons Bill Clinton we do know
that he hacks for marital Affairs we do
know that any extramarital affairs with
people who weren't even necessary
willing we do know that he lied about it
in court doesn't even care anyway keep
turning in 2017 2017 you realize oh yeah
[Laughter]
this is breaking news look at here
something with Democrats not only is it
swept under the rug they become fixtures
Ted Kennedy now Ted Kennedy has like a
heat up at a 40-year career after he was
soliciting sixteen-year-old girls 12
after he had an affair with Mary Jo
Kopechne he left her in the river for
dead he serves for 40 more years after
that so Roy Moore we didn't have any
evidence there wasn't even been a trial
yet it was these were just allegations
now it seems there might've been some
weight to it and that was enough for 40%
of Republicans who voted for Donald
Trump to abandon the guy Ted Kennedy
killed a broad and solicited teenagers
he was the only one who Marilyn Monroe
wasn't willing to blow and he was there
for 40 years I think that's a good thing
I think it's a good thing that at least
there's some standards regardless of the
Roy Moore situation long term we have to
we have to go we have to come back and
to take this test with blaring damn than
climate damn
[Music]
[Music]
bang kids are dead see what you did you
fell to join weekly rocket your father
join the mark club so we killed all your
little now you don't have any children
now you don't have any children we tell
your kids we said we would you didn't
heed we kept our word you made us do it
we killed your kids you killed
[Applause]
[Music]
Am I
[Music]
Oh
sitting there said he enjoyed doing the
show so I'm coming back he always seems
like he like he's he's won one show of
ours away from losing his career
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
what's going on guys why with the music
it's watching homeland ladder with
Crowder studios is protected exclusively
by Walther and hopper
[Music]
system reversing it you watch all Jack
Dempsey when you do this and then boom
throw the punch I don't know how but
this would this would actually fool
people maybe like what what is he doing
with those am i still in a boxing match
I lost alright next guest we have had
this wonderful guest on several times
you can follow her on the youtubes at
ute well it's not at that's on the
Twitter youtube.com slash Blair White X
there you go X the X is important
eration ex expect Triple H to come out
here any second how are you Blair well
we're glad to have you on so we let you
know beforehand so no one can say we
sandbag ya none of us want to do this
and we knew that you wouldn't want to do
this so we thought let's all be unhappy
together thanks for dragging me in the
[ __ ] Howard after the break by the way
this comes from everyday feminism calm
and it's a quiz we're all gonna take 10
things every intersectional feminist
should ask on a first date now Blair
before you roll your eyes and I'm sure
you already are yeah explain for people
who don't know the term intersectional
feminist
okay so intersectionality is basically
it's what feminists believe that like
women in general and people experience
oppression and like varying degrees so
it's basically like the white people
aren't good enough the belief system
it's basically like it's not enough to
be a feminist and advocate for women you
have to focus on you know black issues
and how they Trump women's issues and
then it goes into like disabled people
and then it goes into like I don't know
down syndrome babies do you swear you
haven't read this quiz yet yeah
everybody because you just like we don't
need you just hit the quiz well I see
it's not for people out there you know
that's not all live in this world where
we understand it a lot of people go
what's intersectional feminism I mean
they wear it as a badge of honor I had
no idea what an that until there's now
until just now
you just learned it I mean that Cotton's
gender on skype I could guess the wonder
of new media I could guess but I
wouldn't even right now right okay this
is for me Blair if you may oh you may
open it so we can all go through this in
real time everyday feminism calm I have
hard copy here cuz we're gonna we're
gonna take notes we're ready and people
on the Twitter you can tweet all of us
and let us know your you're going along
with quiz you knock knock' Jared at s
Crowder man G Morgan Jr and a - are
white miss Blair white miss Blair white
MS Blair white okay okay
okay the number one question the top ten
questions at every intersectional
feminist should ask Anna first date huh
let me preface this okay before it's a
date right so you would think these
Russians and first date first date first
date so you would think that the
questions would center around something
relational like are you Lord of the
Rings guy or like Harry Potter you're
right you have a penis I don't know it's
a guessing game you don't know it's a
roll the scattegories dice oh yeah cards
against humanity' yeah exactly
okay number one question on a first date
do you believe that black lives matter
is a trick question
yes wonderful let's start here there are
three categories that are non
negotiables understanding race class and
gender okay number one question I guess
we have to answer that I didn't plan
this far ahead do you believe that black
lives matter so Blair you get this on a
first date with an intersectional
feminist how do you how do you answer
what you think of the movement yes it's
capitalized black marks from the
movement for a while yeah I don't know I
think de Rais doing a guy in the back of
a car go baby okay answer because right
away I want the date to get over with
I'm cheating right now it's kind of like
when I get really bored at poker not get
your notice I just put down all my chips
on a bad hand thank you yeah yeah I
think I would actually say no and then
go with the I think all eyes matter just
to be just to push it one step further
no I don't actually I think all lives
matter
naca Jerry I'm going to say our what
shade of black are we talking about
this Imam has come they're all shades of
black I can go with that
and one of the benefits of being
partially colorblind all right so pretty
much all of us are going to hell
according the first so there let me just
write that little note there yeah look
at number two on a first date this is of
course Blair's or guests look a sensor
first what are your thoughts on gender
and sexual orientation let me preface
that says the gender e to gender binary
is a tiny box and I wish it didn't exist
I wouldn't want to be with anyone who is
queer phobic one of the many important
elements in dismantling patriarchy is to
abolish gender roles okay anyway so this
is all interesting but what are your
thoughts on gender and sexual
orientation on a first date first off
would you ask this on a first date where
does it say down towards the end laugh
oh yeah I know what misogyny is are they
trying to say it's a new Tim Burton
massage I mean like misogyny against
black trans I don't know maybe yeah cuz
nor you don't know this you don't know
this Blair mail have no no none your
that your consultant all right that's
all okay that's number two to number
three first date how do you work to
dismantle sexism and misogyny in your
life Blair with my boyfriend I guess
that always seemed to be my thing okay I
don't this is like the worst it is
that's the whole purpose of it was
crucial for sis had men to learn to
dissenter their male privilege
yes D Center ya de Center okay gerald
how would you Wow let's say you get
asked this how do you dismantle sexism
misogyny in your life I don't dismantle
anything but if somebody's being sexist
I call them out on it they're being
misogynistic I call them out on it I'm a
man and you do you think that's all you
have to do yes that's an example of
massage I think that you don't think you
do more Jared calling somebody out some
F
I don't work at all I've already hired a
female assistant to bring me lunch all
right only number four first date again
what are your thoughts on sex work oh
cool to not be a hooker hooker Tuo's
yeah got it
okay let me see what is it they said
they say you may scratch your head of
this one but much like racism and
misogyny or can someone bring up
massaging you are I'm gonna I'm on it
okay Google right now being pro sex
worker is a necessary pillar of
dismantling the patriarchy okay here's
something I don't understand being Pro
sex worker it's the oldest profession in
existence yeah because of patriarchy
like yeah yeah I mean how does this how
is this pulling up like oh you outweigh
what you support sex workers Oh No okay
according to Wikipedia so this is this
is authoritative misogyny Juarez
misogyny directed towards black women
where race and gender both play roles
and bias it was coined by queer black
feminist Moya Bailey who created
directed toward black moon in America
visual popular culture blah blah blah
yeah well it doesn't you know what
because it's it's in the question where
are your thoughts on gender and sexual
it has nothing to do with race so this
writer doesn't indicate the word I know
massage Anwar yeah yeah yeah can't it
just be misogynistic in general like why
does it have to be specific to a race
that racist yeah
what does it be passed them I'm sorry if
Ulysses this is really weird this is the
first time it says I mean behind of Pro
hoaxes and where you understand the
labor of sex workers of color especially
trans women of color who engage social
stigmas for good reasons sometimes like
being a hooker is dangerous I don't know
about
feminists like they should probably you
know not advocate for that well this is
like it seems like this question is
written around the character angel from
rent
it's the sex with a trans black sex
worker yeah I mean so bleak there's
gotta be like four it's like yeah your
chances of contracting aids are
significantly higher but what about the
sickle sale I don't know what's in sex
work I just enjoy all my sex works okay
of course number five are you a
supporter of the BDS movement do you
know don't don't fall did you know what
this meant right away
boycott divest sanctions oh my gosh in
an effort to end international support
for Israel's oppression of Palestinians
so this is a this is no question number
five in the first thing by the way at no
point even like for someone obnoxious
has been like are you gluten-free this
is just I mean how does this Blair Blair
these are these are the people who claim
to be your peeps they claim they're
intersectional for you for BDS no no I
think when one side has eradicate all
Jews in their official charter they're
the bad guys the other guys get what
they want that's it I supported the guys
who don't have eradicate all Gaea don't
push me into the sea there you go call
me call me reductive about your into
exactly like are you into BDSM and its
Dick Morris you know the foot fetish Al
Gore gonna be some school ok what are
you into
but BDS you actually might be more
likely to get the wrong answer someone
who thought you said BDSM right that's
true but so what someone like how do you
feel about they're basically saying how
do you feel about Israeli occupation
another person's like Vietnamese sex
hammock stirrups you know you seem well
versed in this Steven continue I'm I've
listened to Rihanna oh there you go
I know okay number six let's go as
though these are interesting questions
number six
what is this is where it really got
party what is your understanding of
settler colonialism and indigenous
rights Blair this was an issue close to
your heart as a transit what does this
say it's committed genocide your
opinions committed genocide okay this is
what this is about how better understand
how settler colonial well you know what
also Europeans did they want to talk
genocide committed some yeah Lobo LC
Europeans kind of paved the way for the
ability to write stupid tests on blogs
like everyday Philip Locke supposed to
disappear a year ago like they lost all
their money or some day Holly's like she
talked about the Young Turks and then
all of a sudden some terrorist
organization swoops in and gives them
another thing I honestly we've talked
about this listen obviously some vets
some atrocities committed on both sides
but yes here's a deal with what you're
talking about settlers about the United
States more particularly if a plaintiff
no one ever came here right and they
still had not domesticated horses they
didn't use the wheel I don't if you know
this player this idea of the horse back
they didn't use the wheel when we came
here this was the New World
give him time Romans did no contact and
a plane goes over now guess what
someone's getting genocided
yeah okay number seven do you I don't
like do you think do you think
capitalism is exploitative this is a
question number seven on a first date
let's who at this point in the date if
you're still here at number seven do you
plow through just for the fun how hot is
this person I mean by the time you get
to seven like you got to be like a ten
straight up ten for me to still be at
the table right committed date rape just
on principle
you're an awful person everybody do you
think capitalism is exploitative that's
depends does it apply to question number
four with the sex worker right you know
here's one thing regardless of your view
and I'm kind of libertarian on that like
I but it does destroy lives
it basically when you're saying let's
tax it and regulate sex work you've
effectively made us the pimp
yeah the taxpayer is now secure that's
all yes it's like well they wouldn't
that case they'd be safe yeah because
the taxpayer were the pimp we're
slapping we're slapping slapping [ __ ]
with sexist Pinos all right you think
capitalism is exploitative I I mean I at
this point like I guess bartender yeah
another bottle of wine please
okay number eight this is okay Blair can
any human be illegal
lured in illegal immigrants that's the
point
they're always some hyperbolic like
you're an illegal human notice you being
here is illegal right kind of like
you're not an illegal person but your
knife in the person's spleen is an
illegal act oh yeah let's hear it's
mind-boggling that borders are even a
thing don't like so the copy will aliens
are illegal is just so inhumane and
despicable let's send you to the third
world and see if you give a damn about
any of these concepts just say to try
survival I don't care about borders I
just I mean I don't here's the thing I
understand there are some things where
they might say hey it boggles the mind
like right now net neutrality the whole
idea of net neutrality are the 2015
rules from Morocco I think most people
don't understand them but I don't say it
boggles the mind that anyone would
support them it boggle or it boggles the
mind that you think your country should
be a country I love this white Americans
stole this Lee and colonized Lee and
created so many borders pushed out kill
and enslave people of color and somehow
they have they'll desk and what point
this intersection now to include the
Africans who came over here and
apparently built the country by
themselves yeah what porn they're
responsible is intersectionality right
yeah at some point there at the culprits
to wait well this Africans you solve
so let me the ones who came no the ones
who came over here the intersectionality
they helped they built America so what
at what point are not just wait a minute
field assistants a good point yeah but
what about the Africans you sold them
okay you know more responsibility I just
go back I don't know miss me with that
bull that's what I'm saying to this quiz
[Laughter]
this is the beauty of like this
intersectional LGBTQA IP put it all
under one umbrella because they just act
as though you don't know if you have to
ask you don't underst you couldn't
possibly understand for two-spirit right
[Laughter]
do you support Muslim Americans and
non-muslim people from Islamic countries
what does that mean yeah so broad oh
that's less less pretty straight from
the lips of the broad in what way I
can't think of any religion any other
religion which has been vilified to
light about more than Islam into
cultural and system Christian systemic
way I'm not a Muslim so I will stay in
my lane I but I cannot abstain my lane
but I could imagine for a second if you
claiming to be a feminist if I didn't
stand in solidarity with my Muslim
friends and family especially now
especially after 9/11 oh don't waste
your time and energy on dating someone
who thinks that Islam is inherently
violent Mohammed said screw me for
reading what if I just showed up what if
a woman just shows let's say this is a
man asking these questions what if a
woman showed up to the date and I don't
have like a pair of pliers on her neck
like Hellraiser so many were like what
why do you have flyers well my dad makes
me wear these like commits this person
is so
intersectional but they actually don't
support odv people LGBT people in Muslim
countries because they're sitting near
denying that Islam is violence that's
actually right Blair let me ask you this
how do you think you would fare in the
great state of Palestine there's no
state of Palestine by the way
I don't know honey I don't think I think
you'd get one year turner Louise it
would be a wonderful shot of you okay
final question this is why I said I will
ask you if you'd read the quiz number 10
does your ally ship there's that word
include disabled folks
alright Blair this is also like as an
abled bodied woman again I will stay in
my lane but she puts the dummy head in
this be mindful of those who mock
disabled people that kind of Cruelty is
inexcusable I'm gonna go the other way
you ever seen ahead with rickets like
back in the day like that's just a
little humor a little capitalism to be
good for him eradicated someone looking
to exploit the the rickets loophole
where they can make a little bit of cash
for the word profit does he laugh would
you have to go and I know you're gonna
be why I can't say but we're this big 16
hour live stream next week and Blair may
or may not be there wink wink
what are you these people they just
intersectionality it obviously it's
really stemmed from the transgender
thing that's were they like they've
latched on to it how frustrating is it
for you to always have to say yes I'm
trans but because I I would assume
run into people who think you you would
agree with this whole time do you say
anything but it is frustrating because
it's like you're it's like half of my
existence on YouTube it's like doing
damage control
it's like correcting people who are
speaking for me who I never asked to
speak for me so it's really questioning
yeah I can imagine how all right well
thank you Blair for being a good sport
this is it everyday feminism dot-com you
know what don't go there don't give them
your phone but you can go to youtube.com
slash Blair White X or at miss Blair
white I thought I was hoping you'd be
more outlandish in your answers like I
don't know sis males come die but we
have to go Clint Howard is banging on
the door and he's out of his mind with
to go see him next we'll see you soon
[Music]
hey guys Merry Christmas and I wanted to
address the elephant in the room this
year there's a lot of people that eat
way too much soy they put soy and
everything but I don't want them to not
have a Christmas or a Christmas song so
I did a remake of an old classic just
for them it's called 12 triggers of
Christmas and I'll do a shorter version
this can be a little long um the first
day of Christmas is something triggered
me a straight couple with the family on
the twelfth day of Christmas is
something triggered me 12 Christians
praying 11 good cops copping 10 trumps
of tweeting nine men succeeding a comics
joking seven armed civilian Sikhs
Russians hacking five whites with no
guilt for soilless watches three
full-time moms two total genders and a
straight couple with the
hey Christmas everyone even the soy boys
[Music]
for you this was for you more than the
audio that's kind of a nipples mo if the
nipples move you know not very well
reviewed but was very popular when I was
in junior Clint Howard for those who
don't know here live in studio who's got
nothing to plug I don't think you mean
you're Clinton Howard what do we plug
it's just like one of the longest
catalogs and all of IMDB history you
know I haven't started becoming some
sort of salesman or I don't sell
insurance or I don't really have a
website I do make snow globes but
they're hideously expensive so I
wouldn't try to sell them to anybody
because I charged two hundred twenty
eight thousand dollars
really yeah it sounds like you're lucky
you're putting me on here you know so
Lenny for that no but if I just sell one
if I just sell one everything will be
cool and you see they can't really fly
yeah yeah I don't mind shirt correct oh
yeah these are my snow globes here yes I
make snow globes and let's see what I
said that's a snow globe inside of a
snow globe and that's a clown and his
name is crappy with a K okay and he's
going to the bathroom there's a commode
and that's a guy in an ivory tower Cecil
okay now do I have to ask her let's just
what's the story behind the snow globes
um you know I've always been kind of
interested in keeping my hands busy and
just being creative and I used to sort
of paint and do multimedia stuff two
dimensionally and it just came up
something to do but you know I've had
artificial hips and I used to play a lot
of golf and without playing golf I kind
of needed something to do so this was
basically a garage project
how many snow globes do you have now do
you think you've made oh I probably made
twenty something I haven't made one in a
while but I've given a few away one
resting piece it no well what happened
is that they become unglued
they were the Pittsburgh Steelers they
were celebrating their championship and
they just
glued from the base so floating Steelers
the ball bit or the Steelers killing the
Steelers inside of the snowglobe were
floating they came unglued and then at
that point you know you can't have
floating unglued more like the Browns at
that point yes yes speaking of that you
know you got to be a little careful
about as you apply stuff otherwise you
don't want any floaties yeah crappy
commode you could get floaties that was
a question do you want floaties or not
now one more thing I have a whirling
dervish gathers no blood clots okay snow
globe and it is a whirling dervish with
one hand lopped off and in it was an
accident it was a dusting accident I had
the whirling dervish he used to have two
hands okay but the the hand got knocked
off I've done horror movies i bloodied
it I put it in a snow globe and he's
like spinning around you're leading to
death because a whirling dervish my
Christmas tree store anytime soon I
don't think no but it's a prized
possession of mine I can imagine we if
we had two hundred and eight thousand
dollars we we'd ask you to make one for
the ladder with Crowder and put it but I
don't know I Drive it that's why one
reason why it's so expensive is I
because I can't fly it I physically
would drive it to you clothes free
vacations at that point basically I
would very patient I would
Boober to ouray if you bought the snow
globe I would kiss your we just we don't
have that kind of cash some more of
these clothes from my club
[Laughter]
Wow you've done so much I mean I know I
won in you you tell us what you wanted
to talk about here today but I know
obviously your dad recently passed yeah
yours Rance Howard Rance Howard you know
I got to work with him actually I might
have something to plug because I did a
movie with him a couple months ago I
guess it's now been three months since
we worked and it's called Appleseed okay
and it's a movie about a guy who spends
50 years in prison and he gets out of
prison he goes on this kind of Odyssey
and he helps everybody that he sort of
comes in contact with and he his journey
is to his sons house and I'm play the
son and I am like the only guy in the
story that just isn't bowled over by
this man because my memories of him are
distorted because of the spit stain
scratched up Plexiglas that I had to you
know grow up when were working this with
with Rance Howard with her dad what did
he do on that he played he was number
one on the call sheet Wow yeah no dad
worked a lot he was in a movie called
broken memories towards the end he
played an Alzheimer's patient he was in
this appleseed and I got to work with
him and Robby Benson is in the movie
Adrienne Barbeau I believe he's in the
movie tell the story it's fascinating
you owe your dad Rance Howard goes from
Oklahoma right out there in the ranches
of Oklahoma how does that come about
because that paved the way for for you
and your brother yes both Ron and I have
certainly talked about it in terms of I
don't think we have the intestinal
fortitude to do what he did or to break
the chains and go from you know to make
a move from Oklahoma you know to
Hollywood let alone I mean Ron being
able to be a storyteller and a producer
of major things and people pay attention
and and just even entertaining yeah
no dad's 42 hit me he was a hick yeah my
dad grew up on a farm and he got the bug
of acting when he was like in the sixth
grade and you know in his high school
his counselor had no idea what Broadway
was right no idea he suggested the
University of Oklahoma they had a drama
department and dad went to the drama
department and realized they were
teaching theory they weren't teaching
any practical how to get
make a living in Chavez right so dad
just as a 20 year old he went out from
Oklahoma in New York got a job as a
shirt a movie theater and he you know he
did have a break I mean some some people
don't get breaks he got a job in the
Broadway play mr. Roberts well some
people don't get breaks but obviously he
said that that fortitude in that kind of
a work ethic it lends itself to being
the kind of guy who's there when the
break can occur well you know also to
you know listen doing an autopsy of his
life yeah I mean he he turned out to be
a really really good dude right and he
was selfless and you know I mean what he
did for Ron and I to put our careers and
he didn't even really think of what we
were doing as a career it was just an
opportunity put some money in the bank
he never spent a nickel of our money I
mean he raised us he fed us he clothed
us he thought all those things it wasn't
like we were participating with our
paychecks right just very unselfish he
taught Lee Van Cleef how to ride now
leave and you had a lifetime of being
probably Hollywood's greatest Western
villain and Lee Van Cleef was in New
York City about dad's age maybe a little
older and he had an audition for High
Noon and he had checked all the boxes of
what he could do you know actors used to
do that can you tap dance of course can
you ride a horse of course well Lee Van
Cleef had an audition for High Noon and
it was going to be down to stables in
Manhattan in Central Park and he got
nervous so this was still when he was in
New York oh yeah okay yeah we believed
they auditioned in high noon in New York
Wow okay and so so dad took Lee Van
Cleef down to the stables in Manhattan
there you know in Central Park for three
or four times and had sessions where he
taught him how to ride Lee Van Cleef got
that part in High Noon
and Lee Van Cleef ended up having that
career I wonder if there's someone out
there right now who would be telling
that story I remember when I saw Raines
Howard and Lee Van Cleef riding horses
in the middle of Central Park they've
been a straightjacket in a padded
yeah you did dad is now here's the thing
they were competitors they were in the
same business right now listen I'm not
saying I wouldn't help a fellow actor
however I think in life and especially
in Los Angeles it's a little become a
little more dog-eat-dog absolutely I
mean I don't think dad I mean leave may
have paid for the the rental horses but
nowadays it would be completely
different right I mean listen dad really
wanted to know if you could get an
audition - well maybe maybe not maybe
not your dad that's speaks to his
character I mean it's like in stand-up
that's like we were just talked about
that before before during the break all
my friends my god man it's a community
everyone supports each other I go yeah
get a get a break get a comedy special
and see how many those people are still
around and stand up it is brutal try to
get laughs on that open mic night when
there's a bunch of unemployed comics
standing around how hots that audience
gonna write you know you see like all
these top comedians and of course we
tell it from a liberal perspective like
Amy Schumer no less people that are just
super far left and you go really so you
just all happen to be best friends the
the top comics out there no what happens
is after they become successful they're
not as threatened they have kind of
their lane and all of a sudden there's
camaraderie but coming up from the what
about the guy who was the open mic or
not bill burr when louis c.k was coming
up you don't know about him people don't
realize that like when louis c.k was
even headlining there were six or seven
other comics right there were also in
the mix there right and they have sharp
elbows yeah and so it's also late at
night and it's not the healthiest
environment in the world it's a little
like rock and roll yeah well you know
plus he's masturbating in the greenroom
so if that makes a little uncomfortable
now I didn't know I didn't know that I
didn't I've only heard of a little
debauchery not necessarily from him but
I've heard debauchery and fun oh no
that's that's what the women came
forward and he said he did you mean
while he was like breaking through as a
comment yeah well I mean he was
relatively successful but he would just
be like you just be fondling you would
be do you be going to town in the green
room I'd imagine I couldn't imagine
spanking it and then expecting to
continue to have a career well in public
I was paying
privately is one thing but I'm sure
making it public I mean you have to
accept the fact that eventually the
dominoes are gonna fall
what's an unwilling participants it's
also just something that wouldn't occur
to me just like a little good wouldn't
he be embarrassed you know someone
walked in on me naked oh I'm sorry
he would her like shuts the door behind
him like look at this just do it for you
they say no and he continued well I
don't know the listen you know more than
I do about this these facts and this is
part of your business my word for it I
try to avoid even thinking too much
about it because really when you when
you do think about it it's really sick
well it is sick and you know it's funny
you've played like we've talked about
you've done some out there roles right
people you're kind of known for
addiction yeah fiction fiction but the
the reality in the entertainment history
you know we've talked about the salaat
when you you deal with they say well
there's a rape culture there's this idea
of you know people are so unhappy and
that's what you see nearly every film
well that the rape culture really only
exists in a few places and Hollywood is
not one of them it's not out there in
Oklahoma the same effect but is this
something you kind of knew about as an
open secret for a long time well no I'm
first of all no I was kept fairly naive
by my parents not naive but I think they
allowed me to be kids as long as
possible in terms of learning about that
stuff about about all bullying in the
workplace I mean when you really think
about it there's somebody a power that
somebody potentially could be hiring he
almost never is not at work right and so
if he makes a move on somebody or even
if that woman thinks he's making a move
on her with the illusion that it might
include employment we have a serious
litigation issue here right so anyway
it's like it can be a sticky wicket
there there have always been alpha
guards yeah there's always been alpha
dog CNE in the insurance job you know
actually insurance is kind of part of my
game these days okay but were you
surprised like what the Weinstein and as
the allegation just kind of started
coming out was it something that
surprised you know you mean that people
do doggish things like what apparently
bill cosby may have done
yeah yeah no that means we still have to
say alleged but I mean well yeah well I
wasn't there and I haven't seen evidence
or anything but I listen I was when I
was in my early 20s I heard that mr.
Cosby I believe the term dog was used as
a sort of not so affectionate nickname
for him yeah so it's not something that
it's just you know now the fact that
there may or may not have been like
drugs kind of mixed in there to sort of
help lubricate the situation that's
really sick right but just even a
middle-aged man out you know kind of
trolling is that's just something it's
just not quite did you tell anyone like
take advantage like trying you know take
advantage now you know in a sense of to
even just like come on to you I I've had
that like Gabe wardrobe people grabbing
my ass I've talked about that before
pretty common I'll tell you what I did
recognize the first gay man that I've
worked with and I mean he was 14 I was
14 years old and he didn't do anything
he was a wardrobe guy when his name was
Dyke and and you know I he was a nice
guy and he never made a movie never
genitalia nothing no brush nothing right
you know but he's attorney now I'm sure
yeah well I don't know old Dyke he was a
good guy yeah but old I certainly spent
too much time about the urinating in the
shower when you have cold water hitting
industry where listen you just you got
to keep your head in a swivel and we've
had some people aren't gonna like lesson
of course this doesn't surprise us we
know this has been going on for a long
time I think obviously like said you
started working so young too you were
somewhat shielded from it in the sense
that you had great parents by the time
you were old enough they didn't have the
same kind of leverage like hey Clint if
you want to work in this industry yeah
come on over to the Weinstein bouncy
house well yeah you see I I don't think
it happens every time I'm sure and I
don't think I mean listen I if somebody
would have taken a liking to me I think
having good parents I don't believe my
parents ever put me in a position where
I could have been manipulated that's
really that's that's a good way to put
it that's parents who do a good job in
the industry we were children I mean if
that happens now I know actresses that
had were juveniles and I don't want to
get names and I know it but I know that
they in their minds or the reality is
there were older filmmakers that had
that
you with no argument you could say they
took advantage of them oh absolutely
so I mean that's just wrong but that's
human nature I listen I know if you add
the fame filter and you know this people
treat you very very differently if you
meet someone who doesn't know Clint
Howard as Latinos bye-bye well okay
treat you differently from someone who's
at comic-con right it's just it's
there's a psychology with it it's an
entirely different relationship right
off the bat predators have power and
when prep when when a predator is a
powerful person and a predator being
somebody that you know comes on right a
predator when powerful the the the
victim will fear sure career when
they're in on janu some hey listen
there's no denying that oh he touched me
I'm sexually harassed right yeah I mean
listen you don't think that getting
publicity at the advantage and
shortchanges the actual victims and you
just have someone saying like wow you
know you could have accused our makeup
artist of sexually harassing you because
they had to get all up in there when now
yesterday I've got one I love I'll tell
you in a couple of years before I get
sued but I've got a good one about
makeup and a green makeup and slow
erotic dance oh you told us about
flipside kind of a little take that in a
softer approach and we dictate goes off
to green not sexual harassment but that
kind of position of power he talked
about this in the industry with with
Trump and the conservative issue this
last election that happens as well as
well listen we're lording the power over
you if you don't if you don't think the
right way you're not a lot of the cool
kids club again you're beyond it because
you have such a catalogue of work but
you think I'm beyond so you've
experienced that still well experienced
did it's a factor it's just you know now
listen I would not go over to any
executives house knowing that there was
gonna be you know debauchery and and and
and sodomy or whatever I just would
choose not under the general debauchery
umbrella
but there are kids there are young
actors or actresses that would gambol
brand even if at you know here's a
chance for me to make it in my career
right yeah it won't be so bad I don't
mean literally getting stooped but being
a being in an uncomfortable situation
they can gamble well that way I know
that of course I'm saying you think goes
even a step further so if they're
willing to take that kind of a gamble if
they're anything even remotely right of
far-left you know you keep your mouth
shut if you want to work if you're a
young kid oh yeah you mean like if some
pervert to the passe no no I'm tell my
politics now the Trump factor I'm saying
we go way far we have sexual harassment
warning power but I remember people
invited me to an Obama fundraiser I'll
say it now is it was three arts was
three artists we were sitting down we
were looking at different management and
I said no thanks and then questions came
and I just they were furious well okay
then that then they probably would have
been bad management to begin with right
listen and you know what I did not call
Very Berry until his presidency was over
I have a respect for you know the office
and every say he was he was Obama but
you know I did a snowglobe about Barry
yeah and he's got kind of a bruised chin
and it's just not that it's a huge
political statement it might be some
jelly or it might be a bruising but
there's no there's no crappy commode in
there with him right
he's a bobble head but it wasn't until
after he you know he was president
stopped being president well yeah I
think it's no secret that obviously
you're one of the the more outspoken
sort of conservatives in Hollywood
because at this point you are who you
are you and Gary the claws cut yeah for
young people I would say my dad always
said this keep the politics your job is
not politics your job is to entertain
right you know and so for somebody
starting out regardless of right or
wrong
conviction is one thing and and
religious conviction spiritual
conviction is one thing but you'd be
doing yourself a favor in the business
yeah if you kept your mouth shut
yes exactly unless you're in a green
room with Louie CK and you want to move
up the stand-up ladder then wide open we
have double stick tape
back to the green page story top stick
is this very good quality come back
Clint Howard thank you so much for being
here sir it's been a pleasure and these
are cold and seriously you're dancing
with that you like good
[Music]
we I love little family trunk I mean
your brother really embarrassed you he
didn't do [ __ ] hmm don't stop on my
account
did you finish the song you gonna finish
the song
are you let's stay with you
there's your song for me I love little
Christmas cheer finish the song
Christmas tree Mike spurts tree
[Music]
I don't know why I actually stopped
breathing here and I don't know why we
could just pantomime it I think it's the
commitment to Daniel day-lewis sort of
tax today Lewis sort of thing he went on
a ride-along so we know what it's like
to be a cop he knows all about it
gosh the method actors if you know like
I get into character we do things that's
really because I understand needing to
get in something not breaking getting in
your mind but people who act like I've
never uh I I know what it's like to be a
Mohican really I'll were saying I went
down to the gift shop and I spoke with
2000 and he told me what it was like and
then I had dinner with him at the Chop
House in the traditional Indian garb so
I appreciate Clint hours a lot of fun
Clint Howard a lot of must by the way
behind the scenes also a lot of he's
exactly expect he's very he's really
sharp
he's very when he stones in yeah but
when he doesn't when he doesn't feel
like when he just sort of relaxed she's
like I miss it was like a ping-pong ball
[Music]
you're like yeah he said he's your dad
how many pictures of him in a hot tub it
was like a it was a documentary of his
travels and yeah it photos that would
have made Ron Jeremy blush like it was
weird but it wasn't at all like this is
just Clint this is just Clint it's been
next week of which next week all of your
Crowder favorites will bring up the card
here when we talk about power ah going
to be on the live 16 our CNN live stream
and the series premiere of a YouTube
carol yes
the story of Ebony's are you to board
emption YouTube Christmas past really
they're going will he get right with his
covetous sinful censoring way sinful man
will see we will see probably won't you
just talk we were some of this kind with
Clint he was just mentioning and you
were talking about this how his parents
shielded him from kind of a fifth all
very interesting that is very cool well
he often you don't hear it very often
here kids who were just just just
royally screwed in Hollywood oh yeah but
yeah and now we turn a blind eye to it
when it's Chaz what's Chaz
jazz is jazz I am just yeah Chazz is a
[ __ ] jazz the [ __ ] the ass [ __ ]
gang yeah so you really like the Z's
they really lose as well dizzy they also
want to use Z pronouns maybe there's a
tie in there no idea I never even
thought of this before blowing the lid
water no I know what Zeke Romans think
about now we just ignore it
we knew with Corey Haim and Corey
Feldman I am jazz it's gonna have sex
change it had a sex change operation now
can't couldn't actually do it
successfully because I wasn't enough
material to make a fake vagina no no one
wants to talk about how this is
exploiting a child no it's because it's
still not cool wasn't cool back then
it's not cool now it was never cool for
parents to shield I guarantee you the
kids on set we're Clinton losers yeah
which is funny because it's just it's
coming full circle now we're the people
who are honest themselves I think you're
waking up to see that you know you tie
that in with with Mike Pence who was
mocked what eight months ago yeah all
the comments about being you know loyal
to his wife and not being caught you
know one-on-one with the woman board
these accusations could even you know be
seriously you know taken taken seriously
right and mocked mocked mocked mocked
because sure Clint out Rose mock because
it wasn't cool was it cool it was and
now you're like Mike Pence what a dork
yeah what a loser
that betcha no one comes out Nick what
is it whatever of rape in a room because
no one's there or what a super predator
because he can't be around right it's
just by the honest people are realizing
that oh people with some standards and
some some freaking values may have had
it right well you know and I think a lot
of it if you look at the alt right and
sort of Trump in it and no one cares
about your principles or your values
actually turns out half of the people
who you thought were your buddies do
with Roy more and more wasn't really
cool with the Trump thing to say you
know what this prop this really isn't
gonna play well so yeah just so much
winning winning yeah who cares no one
cares turns out a lot of people care
wasn't cool to say I remember at that
point it caught so much flak I said
listen I think he's better than Hillary
absolutely but if he said that about my
wife I would kick his ass wasn't cool to
say that well guess what now forty five
percent of people who showed up for
Trump didn't show up for Roy more
sometimes it's not cool sometimes the
right thing is not cool when I was on
set remember DW and Arthur it was a boy
who did the voice of DW won't say which
one so that way he was just seized he
just made fun of my wieners cuz I was 12
I was 12 and he was 13 and
you know just smoke and weed and now
just would a dork because my parents
were really also pretty protective me
when I was on set as a kid you know as
I'm said quite a bit it was not cool it
was not cool at all not cool for Mike
Pence to do that not cool this is
another thing people say old man your
ideologue I don't believe you know what
I just take every issue individually of
course you take every issue individually
that's how you become someone with
principles and then you find out which
worldview lines up with your principles
no no world you lines up 100% with all
of your principles no political party
does hell not even any religion out
there does but when you take every issue
individually you say okay this is my
list of non-negotiables and it's not
cool because we don't like labels man
well vody take it yeah dee dee dee forty
years to take your list and you line it
up with who is closest to your list in
this case yeah this way I've always I'll
never vote for a Democrat I'm not a
registered Republican I don't I don't
think I am I don't think it wasn't last
day because of the primary laws but
still I wouldn't very open about it
we'll give too much of an ideologue
really what do you believe well I don't
know I think it's soaked but then I
think Roy Moore is kind of a dick in it
you know I'd support them net neutrality
but and I think the death tax is a good
idea but I don't you know but I because
who needs more than 11 million oh yeah
you're really taking issues and
individually really you're thinking of
this world through the lens critically
play no I just it amazes me here's
nothing it's not cool at all to have a
world view it's not cool to be an
ideologue when everyone who's ever been
successful ever has had an ideology
whether it's sports whether it's
politics whether it's philosophy whether
it's the realm of intelligencia even if
it's in a philosophy some kind of world
you to your work approach you know
here's one thing I find really
interesting and I hear this more and
more we heard it the other day from
somebody I won't the name who it was but
it was a someone who identified as a
liberal but he said but don't worry I'm
an open-minded liberal I think at one
point in time that used to be assumed by
liberals that hey they were the
open-minded ones exurbs were the were
the the dogmatic ideologic you know
illogical ones who were in lockstep all
all the time but I think now it's more
assumed more and more often that if you
label Cerf a conservative it's assumed
you're more open-minded the
well you know what you know I'm liberal
but I'm open-minded you know I said
because it's really it was for the
longest time was really uncool to be
conservative yeah right so I'm
open-minded
okay so yeah they don't want to be one
of the uncool kids that's why I was a
hate of the term libertarian as I'm a
libertarian conservative to describe my
views I certainly would be much more
libertarian than many people out there
who claim sure Batarian but Bill Maher
Greg Gutfeld and Glenn Beck all claim to
be libertarian so it doesn't mean
anything anymore let's say I'm more
libertarian in my views of limited
government but I'm a conservative I
would go out of my way to say that
because I knew it was trying to shuck
the uncool label of conservative that's
uncool you know it's really uncool to
have no idea what it is that you believe
it's to me the death tax was so simple
we talked about that earlier this week
and someone going Steve someone actually
said this I said about net neutrality
death tax is such a great example that
Steven's either a a sheep be a shell or
C is too much of an ideologue to see his
own party's BS no one needs more than 11
million in death tax
I was ok on a second first off yeah the
big big death tax has paid me off I mean
who pays for the death tax which who
would be the adversary the death tax
aside from people who want to pass on
their financial legacy to their children
but here's something just it's really
simple and this can only be a response
when you have a role obviously well how
do you prepare for the change my mind
you know what it's simple when you're ok
with the fact that you have an ideology
my geology means that all men are
created equal they're free the
government doesn't have the right to
tell you what you can or can't do in
your own home what you can say it
doesn't have the right to tell you if
you can or can't defend yourself doesn't
have the right to take your stuff
doesn't have the right to take more than
half your stuff after it's already tax
you're after yourself or this person who
needs eleven million dollars especially
when those lazy kids haven't earned it
big death tax it's just that this is
grim reaper in a suit this for a second
especially with the especially the kids
haven't earned any republicans but you
always about earned the kids in earn it
neither did you
it couldn't be you wouldn't be able to
understand this is a dogmatic to think
hey listen yeah my kids didn't earn that
money maybe my kids were raised with a
silver spoon who knows maybe my kids are
wealthy they also happen to be really
good kids but they didn't earn it
neither did you mister wants to take 65
or 68 percent depending if it's Barack
Obama or Hillary Clinton so this comes
down to your ideology it comes down to a
really uncool being an ideologue who
deserves it more my children or debbie
Wasserman Schultz you're picking
somebody who hasn't earned it but it's
not cool it's not cool to sit down and
say oh because I am a conservative I
think that's wrong oh you know what
because I am a conservative these
principles if Roy Moore if remorse
sexual assaulted someone I have a
problem with it now you have that with
the alt-right right they go after new
knowing your conservative principles are
dying remember that yeah all these we're
going after ben shapiro and myself oh
you're gonna die with your principles no
now you're dying when you abandon the
principles you see what happens it's not
cool to shield your kid as Clint's
parents it's not cool to say I'm not
going out with women who aren't my wife
it's not cool to say you're a
conservative not cool to say that you
have a religious worldview but sometimes
it's the best thing you know it really
isn't cool this is one thing too it's
really not cool to work hard think about
that the whole idea of cool is being
nonchalant in any sport right you'd have
these kids who would want to endzone
dance or throw the ball and I played
sports as a kid before they got good
when I did when I was competing a
Brazilian [ __ ] so you would have these
kids come with all of the all of the the
gays and the new gear and they would
just walk up and try and be like listen
minutes about flowing about being
relaxed and they would get smoked from
the uncool kid who spent 20 hours a week
drilling one with it's not cool it
doesn't look awesome it's not the slam
dunk stick your son you stick your
tongue out at the camera but you're a
Clydesdale you're putting the work and
usually the uncool thing is the right
thing as a matter of fact almost always
and it's not just to be contrarian
almost always if something is labeled
cool it's wrong I mean from from from
from torn Levi's to MC Hammer the stupid
your girlfriend to share to being gender
non-binary LGBTQA AIP and a number two
we're gonna look back on this trend and
say remember when that was cool man we
were really dumb so don't give a rat's
ass about cool stop thinking about cool
look
and all these stories through the prism
of cool and that's what's so ironic is
you're an ideologue really your ideology
is trying to be cool and then you say
keep it real brah really keep it real
brah as long as it's witty within this
this context of cool well I'm keeping it
real I'm keeping it real I don't go out
to dinner with someone alone he's not my
wife loser
yeah you know what I'll take loser I'll
take uncool loser over a lifetime of
being a loser but hey you're one cool
losing bastard see you next week
that is December 21st Thursday 16 hour
livestream CNN that's torturous worse
than water burn that's why we're doing
[Music]